en numéro 5 on commence avec le film bis
qui est sorti en 2015 et réalisé par
dominique farrugia dans lequel vous
jouiez aux côtés de kad merad vous
rappeler ou pas bon au moment de vaud 17
ans et dans cet extrait voulait fitch et
des films sortis récemment au producteur
claude berri ça c'était très fort vrai
un chevalier toutacoo par le biais d'un
passage un chevalier et son goût et son
que son son palefrenier balle cognée qui
serait qu'il serait très sale très très
très nerveux
contrairement aux chevaliers qui lui est
qu'il eut une belle stature une belle
stature et il se retrouve propulsé dans
le dans le présent c'est très drôle
parce qu'on pourrait imaginer que le
personnage qui est jouée par le gueut le
petit peu nerveux entendu des mots
d'aujourd'hui comme par exemple on dit
souvent hockey aujourd'hui grâce à vao
qu'est ça va lui de lille le reprendrai
ma sa manière c'est plus de 45 millions
d'entrées vous rendez compte pas plus de
45 millions d'entrées ayant un film qui
a cartonné en 2018 c'est ton premier
signe tout le monde debout
le mec tu réalises vous jouiez également
avec alexandra lamy qui est exceptionnel
dedans franchement ce film on l'a tous
aimé on a hâte de voir le nouveau film
de franck et pour une première
réalisation
vous avez vous le voyez plus de 2,3
millions de téléspectateurs
énorme carton et dans le film une jeune
fille vous propose de vous aider au
quotidien parce qu'elles pensent que
vous êtes handicapé on va voir l'ex tôt
vous vous rendez compte que ça peut être
un bon moyen pour la draguer regarde
cigares de j je m'occupe de gens comme
vous donc si jamais vous avez besoin de
chercher du travail le chômage comme
tout le monde et enfin voila si jamais
le jour de mois
oui mais c'est laisser se venger je le
fais moi-même juste peut-être si vous
pouvez me donner la petite bobine qui
est là dans l'eau là c'est là pour
changer vous à côté ça
la voilà merci je ne pas laisser traîner
ça il ya une petite aiguille et qui
sortait ses piques les pieds vous savez
c'est un énorme succès comme ça sur ton
prenois n'ont pas autant non non non je
pensais pas on espère toujours que ça
marche mais non tant que ça non j'en ai
j'espère que tu m'as pitch est aussi le
prochain et tu me l'avais pitch est
celui-là je me rappelle il ya quelques
années
c'est vrai que c'était déjà ce déjà
voilà mais rien qu au pitch on savait
que ça allait être très très fort 2
millions 400 mille entrées que c'est un
carton pour un premier film bravo aux
enfants en numéro 3 c'est les seigneurs
avec 2,8 millions d'entrées tu étais au
casting de ce film est que d'olivier
d'aaron y avait un casting de haut enfin
josé garcia jean pierre maria del mar et
omar sy ramzy là vous jouez le rôle de
david léandri un joueur qui veut devenir
acteur et dans cet extrait vous
interprétez cyrano de bergerac six mois
monsieur si j'allais attaquer il
faudrait sur le champ que je me la pète
un salut amical mais il doit tremper
dans votre temps ce qu'est ce que c'est
que ces conneries on est obligé de la
garder cette tirade là je veux dire
c'est pas cyrano c'est pinocchio
allo
il y avait également vincent touya re
corrige à la trilogie réalisée par
fabien otteniente il a cartonné camping
3 fait plus de 3 millions d'entrées
camping 2 4 millions d'entrées et
camping presque 5 des regrets
[Applaudissements]
alors on apprenne extrait du premier
camping dans lequel vous jouez au volet
est votre partenaire antoine duléry
n'est pas dans son match et ça ça vous
énerve autant tu fais chier le temps un
polo tout comme une vraie elle arrête
plus toi tu peux si on joue comme ça
contre lui nous disent ils vont nous
rend [ __ ] une déculottée et moi les
gars je vous préviens j'en ai marre de
me faire battre chaque année par une
équipe de mecs qu'on l'accepté pas l'air
qui a fait le plus grand nombre d'entrés
elles tu as joué qui a fait le plus
grand nombre d'entrées c'est quoi fait
dans lequel je suis astérix et obélix
aux jeux olympiques 6,8 millions
d'entrées vous jouez le rôle d'assurance
turix le barde
on a ressorti un extrait dans lequel
vous étiez accompagné d'un célèbre
musicien regarder vers bis
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames les amis
s'il vous plaît il laisse la place de
professionnels c'est gentil j'aimerais
vous présenter un collègue barde
vous allez voir une énorme élan
[Musique]
francis lalanne x salut selon l'apix je
vous demande de lui fait un triomphe
dans l'âme moi ça fait du garros
tout ça allait continuer ou pas du tout
non je tombe pas je vais us a déjà eu ça
dans le jeu lui-même à un peu plus à ce
qu'à chaque fois ça se cumulent colonna
mais puis avec toute ressemblance qui a
dû faire sans sa ferrari l'entrée ça se
sache
cent cinquante mille entrées non sais je
sais je l'avais vue oui mais j'ai pas
continuer dresse assez incroyable c'est
énorme il ya des fictions des succès
puis on a 12 ans au moins et puis le
film et c'est parce qu'on fait + qui me
plaît ce lieu c'est vraiment dans le
film doté plus fier pour moi et je te le
dis est tombé il ya de nos meilleurs
films je te jure pour moi c'est le
sait-on film forcément sa mort est que
cela dont je suis le plus fier parce que
je les fais maintenant je suis fier
d'eux en général je suis content de tous
les frais réellement de demandes a fait
même les moins bons les mois réussis les
le jeu j'ai aucune tu sais parfois
mondial lui le réalisateur a loupé son
film moi je trouve jamais c'était un tel
travail de faire un film bat quand ils
passent à côté du public ou à côté d'eux
mêmes de ce que devait être le film est
toujours on a passé de bons moments
ensemble a tout fait pour on ya cru et
puis voilà quoi je critique a pas un
film que j'ai fait même s'il n'a pas
marché qu'il a été moins bon que ce que
je pensais